das dritte entlastungs paket der
bundesregierung und die reaktionen
darauf die wollen wir vertiefen und dazu
ist mehr zugeschaltet live aus berlin
der partei- und fraktionschef der afg im
bundestag und in deutschland tino copala
guten morgen nach berlin guten morgen
herr pofalla jetzt gibt es mehr geld für
rentnerinnen und rentner es gibt geld
für studierende die sozialleistungen
werden erhöht es soll eine art strom und
gaspreis bremse kommen deutschland wie
zufrieden sind sie mit diesen vielen
maßnahmen aus dieser langen liste
ja man muss erstmal eingangs natürlich
sagen die bundesregierung hat ein
wuchtiges paket angekündigt am ende sind
es doch wo es almosen geworden denn die
wuchtigen preise die werden jetzt
erstmal für die bürger entscheidend
werden die dieses jahr noch kommen bevor
überhaupt entlastungen greifen werden
also die strom- und gasrechnung die
jetzt im herbst bei den vielen bürgern
jetzt schon eintrudeln die schockieren
viele leute und bringen auch viele
menschen an existenznot und da hat die
bundesregierung absolut nichts getan die
ursache die ursache wurde immer noch
nicht bekämpft das ist der
wirtschaftskrieg gegenüber russland die
sanktionen laufen weiter von daher wird
die preisspirale weiter nach oben gehen
auf diese wie sie sagen
wirtschaftskrieg von h wegschauen wir
gleich noch bleiben wir noch mal bei
diesem paket selbst die afg hat in den
bundestag eingebracht im sommer auch ein
gesetzesentwurf für die entlastung von
rentnerinnen und rentnern da ging es um
300 euro genau diese zahlt die ampel
jetzt zum ersten dezember warum sind sie
dann so unzufrieden ja das ist wie
gesagt erst mal ein erster schritt ist
wurden einige wenige punkte übernommen
das ist richtig zum beispiel auch die
aussetzung der co2 abgabe ab nächstes
jahr wenngleich wie die abschaffung
gefordert haben wir fordern auch
weiterhin die mehrwertsteuersenkung für
grundnahrungsmittel bzw aussetzung weil
das auch wirklich breite schichten
familien aber auch natürlich rentner
entlasten soll es ist auch richtig dass
die rentner jetzt ein stück weit mit
entlastet werden ich bin gespannt wie
der bürokratische aufwand sein wird von
diesen 300 euro wir haben es ja schon
beim letzten entlastungspaket gesehen wo
die rentner nicht dabei waren dass der
bürokratische aufwand mit 800 millionen
euro doch wirklich viele schon
aufgefressen hat von diesen geldern also
was am ende übrig bleibt viele rentner
leben von und das reicht gerade mal für
den zuschlag für gas oder für heizung
für einen monat was die bundesregierung
jetzt auszahlt also es bei weitem nicht
ausreichend wenn sie sagen es sei bei
weitem nicht ausreichend vielleicht
könnten sie dann noch mal sagen was
konkret würden sie denn ergänzend noch
vorschlagen welche maßnahmen auch die in
diesem paket nicht drinnen sind möchte
denn die afd
also wie dieser grundsätzlich müssen wir
an die ursache rein verschieben wie er
dieses problem von monat zu monat wir
haben ist das dritte entlastungspaket
insgesamt von einem volumen von 95
milliarden euro am ende muss ja auch
gesagt wenn es muss jemand bezahlen es
bezahlen die bürger der stadt profitiert
aktuell von dieser inflation er nimmt
massiv steuereinnahmen ein auf jedes
produkt auf jede ware auf jeden auf
jeden artikel sind mehrwertsteuersätze
oben also hier ist linke tasche rechte
tasche das ist ein taschenspielertrick
die bürger zahlen 1000 euro auf der
linken tasche und bekommt in der
regierung 200 300 euro zurück das reicht
bei weitem nicht aus ich habe es
eingangs gesagt die mehrwertsteuer muss
gesenkt werden auf energie
beziehungsweise ausgesetzt werden
grundsätzlich im übrigen nicht nur für
die verbraucher und für die familien
sondern auch für die mittelständischen
unternehmen wurde so gut wie nichts
getan weil den nutzt eine mehrwertsteuer
bzw den steuersenkungen in dieser form
überhaupt nichts fragen sie ihren
bäckermeister um die ecke was eigentlich
diese gas umlage bedeutet und die muss
auch abgeschafft werden die ist
ungerecht sie trifft im mittelstand sie
vernichtet dem mittelstand ein
bäckermeister zahl pro monat 20.000 euro
nur gas umlage er müsste es weiter um
legen viele bäckereien schließen viele
mittelständische betriebe sind in
existenzieller not für die wurde in
diesen entlastung so genannten
entlastungspaket überhaupt nichts getan
also es gibt ja eine strompreis bremse
die auch für unternehmen greifen soll es
ist auch so dass für energieintensive
unternehmen noch mal 1,7 milliarden
entlastungen bereitgestellt werden herr
gruppen haben sie ja jetzt auch noch mal
summen genannt eine
mehrwertsteuersenkung ins spiel gebracht
wie wollen sie denn eigentlich das ganze
finanzieren wenn sie der regierung schon
taschenspielertricks vorwerfen hier
ja das habe ich ja eingangs gesagt die
sanktionen die wirtschaftsfeindlichen
sanktionen müssen weg weil sie schaden
deutschland und wenn die
sanktionspolitik beendete das werden wir
auch wieder günstiges gas aus russland
beziehen können des weiteren ist die
regierung bislang auf vielen fragen
ausgewichen hat sie denn überhaupt gas
in russland bestellt es wird immer von
lieferschwierigkeiten bzw nichtlieferung
russischen gas gesprochen die frage ist
hat die bundesregierung haben die
unternehmen in russland eigentlich gas
bestellt wie sehen die verträge konkret
aus all das wird nicht genannt wird
nicht erörtert also hier bleibt auch
vieles im unklaren auch wir als
opposition wenn im unklaren gelassen das
fordern wir von der regierung und wie
gesagt hier geht es darum dass die
deutschland zuerst an sich denkt dass
hier die bürger entlastet werden es gibt
kein land in der eu und kein land der
welt die überhaupt eine gasanlage
überhaupt verlangen und das fordern wir
dass das zurückgenommen wird das
abgeschafft wird und damit würden die
bürger sofort entlastet jetzt haben sie
das noch mal angesprochen sie haben eben
schon von einem sogenannten
wirtschaftskrieg gesprochen und haben
jetzt hier nochmal auch die
sanktionspolitik kritisiert dann bleiben
wir doch jetzt vielleicht mal dabei also
sie fordern konkret dass die sanktionen
die eu weit beschlossen worden sind wo
deutschland nicht alleine irgendwas
gemacht hat sondern mit allen anderen
eu-ländern sanktionen wegen des
angriffskriegs russlands gegen die
ukraine beschlossen hat sie fordern
diese aufzuheben um dann an nationalen
alleingang zu machen und vor putin zu
kuschen oder wie muss ich mir das
vorstellen es gibt jetzt schon nationale
alleingänge wenn sie schauen wie zum
beispiel die türkei gas bezieht öl
bezieht bei in russland auch ungarn hat
sonderrechte bekommen die geht es nicht
um alleingänge sonder richtig muss ich
auch die eu klar werden was wollen wir
wollen wir uns weiter abhängig machen
von natürlich russischen grad aber auch
von amerikanischen fracking gas wollen
wir unsere wirtschaft ruinieren denn
diese muss es ja finanzieren diese
wirtschaft stärkt ja und bezahlt ja das
alles die arbeiter bezahlen sie
arbeitnehmer bezahlen das und wenn wir
unsere wirtschaft unsere mittelstand
ruinieren und das passiert die
mittelschicht wird mit diesen paketen
und auch mit diesen energiepreisen
enteignet also immer mehr werden in
existenzielle nöte geraten und deswegen
muss die ursache bekämpft werden und das
heißt wir müssen unsere interessen
wahren wir müssen endlich als souveränes
deutschland auftreten als souveräner
europäische union und das tun wir nicht
wir machen uns von staaten wie amerika
abhängig nun ist es ja so dass wir im
moment sehr abhängig sind von russland
und da habe ich das so verstanden dass
ihnen das dann doch auch ganz gut passt
welche sanktionen wollen sie aufheben
und wann
also erstmal die gas
dies ist auch das öl-embargo was hier ab
2023 greifen soll und wir sollten uns so
schnell wie möglich auf dem
diplomatischen weg und die
diplomatischen vater finden damit wir
diesen krieg in der ukraine so schnell
wie möglich beenden und das erlebe ich
nicht das sehe ich nicht im gegenteil
die bundesregierung eskaliert weiter
möchte weiter waffen liefern und genau
das lehnen wir ab dazu ist also
ausreichend geld vorhanden diesen
konflikt weiter anzuheizen und das
lehnen wir kategorisch ab also endlich
bitte die diplomatie bemühen damit
wieder frieden in europa herrscht und
damit sich visa auch die
lieferbedingungen für beide länder
natürlich auch verbessern und dass die
bürger davon profitieren können wir
brauchen kostengünstiges gas aus
russland genauso wie wir natürlich
energielieferungen aus anderen ländern
brauchen hier muss es einen energiemix
geben und zum beispiel auch die akw
verlängerung der atomkraftwerke auch das
muss endlich beschlossen werden in
dieser bundesregierung jetzt haben sie
da auch wieder eine ganze menge erwähnt
da vielleicht noch eine nachfrage wie
stellen sie sich denn da irgendwie diese
lösung vor soll man jetzt einfach dann
weite teile der ukraine an putin
abtreten damit die deutschen wieder
günstigere energiekosten haben oder was
heißt das denn konkret was sie da
eigentlich vorschlagen das heißt konkret
dass ich endlich von der bundesregierung
vorschläge erwartet wie man diesen krieg
lösen kann wie man diesen krieg beenden
kann und das ist aufgabe der diplomatie
ich aber hat er vom bundeskanzler scholz
hier wesentlich mehr diplomatische
bemühungen auch mit einbindung ja auch
von mit einbindung von gerhard schröder
der diesen guten draht nach moskau hat
warum soll das nicht möglich sein hier
muss man wirklich über parteigrenzen
hinaus suchen diesen konflikt nicht
ausweiten zu lassen und das fordere ich
ein und nicht weiter diesen konflikt zu
eskalieren
man hat im prinzip mit diesen
wirtschaftskrieg den habe hier begonnen
hat gegenüber russland diese spirale
erst begonnen das ist die ursache der
hohen inflation der hohen energie und
strompreise die fortführen gelaufen sind
das ist die ursache und die muss beendet
und zurückgeführt werden so ehrlich
müssen wir sein da helfen keine kleinen
hilfspakete die jetzt verabschiedet
werden damit will man nur die
bevölkerung ruhig halten damit man im
herbst keine demonstrationen auf den
straßen sieht sagt tino palla bundes
partei und fraktionschef der afg
herzlichen dank für das gespräch das
phoenix tagesgespräch an diesem
montagmorgen
sehr gerne